quelles ont été vos premières pensées en
apprenant ce matin ses nouveaux
attentats terrible d'abord une grande
tristesse
et puis évidemment le sentiment que nous
avons tous que personne ne peut être
épargné ne peut se considérer
aujourd'hui comme épargné nulle part
dans le monde
aujourd'hui il n'ya d'abris contre 7
cette guerre terroriste donc cela ajoute
aux responsabilités des élus dont vous
êtes en ile de france particulièrement
bien entendu bien vendu puisque on voit
que les capitales européennes sont
particulièrement ciblés
la belgique c'est à quelques encablures
de la france ça arrive directement par
la gare du nord en ile de france donc
donc évidemment il ya des vases
communicants qui sont importants et puis
il faut pas se cacher la vérité
tout ça est quand même créé liée à
l'arrestation de salah abdeslam
c'est-à-dire aux attentats de paris il y
à une filière belge qui a commis déjà
des attendus à paris quels sont les
points que vous avez abordé avec le
ministre de l'intérieur et je les
appelais dès la matinée dès qu'on a su
dès qu'on a su la nouvelle pour parler
avec lui des transports en ile-de-france
alors les transports en ile de france
nous avions déjà une vigilance extrême
mais il ne faut pas relâcher nos efforts
et c'est vrai que dès qu'il se passe
trois semaines un mois deux mois de
calme donc on pourrait être tenté de
relâcher la vigilance donc il ne faut
pas relâcher la vigilance et au
contraire moi ce que je lui ai proposé
ce matin et nous allons nous revoir la
semaine prochaine pour en parler c'est
d'accélérer la mise en place d'un
certain nombre de mesures que nous avons
voté dans le cadre du bouclier de
sécurité francs signant alors ce que je
veux mettre en place et bien c'est
notamment un certain nombre
d'équipements de sécurité de nouvelles
technologies pour détecter par exemple
les comportements suspects par le biais
de sur laquelle égard je voudrais aussi
qu' on puisse engager très vite et c'est
un plan que j'ai proposé ce matin
la modernisation du matériel roulant
parce que là aussi alors ça va prendre
plus de temps on bien entendu c'est sur
du plus long terme il faut nous faut
aussi de la vidéo protection dans donc
les rams un volet sécuritaire également
aujourd'hui dans la rénovation des
trains il y aura des portiques par
exemple comme al harraz élus les ont
proposés également dans je pense au sud
de la france alors moi je crois beaucoup
beaucoup plus je crois à deux choses je
crois d'abord à des outils de détection
un peu innovant technologique
technologique et un peu moins
voyons ce que le problème des portiques
c'est que deux classes ont ils sont
impraticables en ile de france nous
avons quatre millions de personnes qui
prennent les transports en commun tous
les jours 4 millions c'est à dire qu en
ile-de-france y en a plus que surtout
les ter et tous les tgv de france
entière lorsque la vérité c'est que vous
pouvez pas mettre un portique
aujourd'hui à la gare du chaton aux
quelques sillons vous avez une émeute et
vous ne pouvez de toutes les façons pas
rentrer c'est très risqué
l'année commence à mettre en place à en
paca good beat en ile-de-france non il
faut pas y compter
après ça dépend des lieux et ça dépend
des situations nous en ile de france
ça ne servira à rien pourquoi je vous
donnerai simplement l'explication c'est
que à châtelet ou mettre des portiques
embolie serait complètement la gare du
châtelet mais à côté de ça vous avez un
réseau maillé de de centaines de gares
donc la vérité c'est qu'il suffirait de
monter dans une petite gare de banlieue
et à ce moment là on aurait pas de
portiques donc la vérité c'est que le
portique n'est pas une panacée en
matière de sécurité en revanche il ya
deux choses qui sont très importantes
c'est la présence humaine et c'est la
vidéoprotection avec des personnes qui
derrière la vidéo en direct sur ce qui
se passe mais il ya aussi des outils un
peu plus technologique par exemple
d'aider des détecteurs d'armes qui sont
pas forcément ce portique sous
lesquelles on masse mais qui peuvent dés
on a des outils qui peuvent détecter
quand on passe devant
donc en fait on n'en voudra vous allez
accélérée pourrait faire de tous voilà
l'idée c'est d'avoir du matériel qui à
certains points stratégiques et sans que
évidemment les terroristes ne le sache
pour aider tikva corps des choses et
nous permettent d'avoir du renseignement
comment ça se passe mars avec le
ministre de l'intérieur il ya une
volonté bien sûr commune d'aborder de
front les sujets
oui alors le mini salle intérieure hui à
une meilleure connaissance et qui est en
charge
mais sur l'île de france mon message a
été simple c'est que je souhaitais que
les 400 policiers et militaires
supplémentaires qui aujourd'hui sont
déployés sur la région sur le réseau
francilien puisse être aussi déployés
dans les gares de grande couronne qu'on
n'ait pas le sentiment qui a finalement
une sécurité à deux vitesses d'abord une
sécurité dans le métro dans le coeur de
paris et que en réalité tout le reste du
réseau soit oubliée donc il m'a garanti
qu'effectivement il y aurait des
patrouilles dans les trains et dans les
gares
y compris sur le réseau de camp rock
roll alors l'idée c'est évidemment on
peut pas tout surveiller tout le temps
au même moment
mais l'idée c'est de faire de procéder
par sonde de faire des contrôles
d'identité j'allais dire aléatoire et
moi je suis très heureuse parce que ça
fait un petit moment que je demande
qu'on puisse procéder à ces contrôles
d'identité dans le cas dans le dans les
transports en commun donc aujourd'hui il
faut pour prendre les transports en
commun pouvoir justifier de son identité
vous savez que c'est la loi savary qui
devrait être promulguée dans les jours
qui viennent
nous attendons vraiment que le présent
la république la première est vite et
que les décrets d'application de cette
loi soit pris très vite cette prise de
conscience quant à la fermeté nécessaire
aujourd'hui pour répondre vous l'avez
senti auprès des autorités de de
l'exécutif aujourd'hui oui mais vous
voyez quand j'apprends à ma grande
stupéfaction cet après midi que le
fichier ce qu'on appelle le personal
name 'record' le fichier des
déplacements en avion en europe mais
toujours pas mis en place parce que les
députés européens n'ont pas réussi à se
mettre d'accord je me dis mais qu'est ce
que c'est que cet aveuglement comment
est-ce qu'on peut après le 13 novembre
et pas de l'expression il ya bernard
cazeneuve réclame avec force ce volcan
sort était décalée dans le temps ce bien
sûr mais là aussi j'appelle à la
responsabilité
on sait que si celui-ci ce fichier n'a
pas été approuvé c'est parce que il ya
une espèce d'alliance contre nature du
front national et j'allais dire des
populistes européens avec une partie de
la gauche l'antique on ne peut pas
aujourd'hui même si on certains pays
n'ont pas été frappés ils doivent être
solidaires de ceux qui le sont
aujourd'hui
et là vraiment je pousse un cri enfin
l'europe pourra réagir
on peut pas être un ventre mou sinon
c'est toute l'europe à se désagréger
peut pas être un ventre mou face à la
menace terroriste
on doit être souverain souverain ça veut
dire prendre au parlement européen les
vraies décisions
il n'y a pas que les parlements français
belge parce que sinon ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire qu'on va vers le retour des
frontières ça veut dire qu'on va vers la
dislocation de l'europe déjà un peu le
cas aujourd'hui en tous les cas le
retour des frontières il ya un scénario
catastrophe dans lequel l'europe ne
survit pas à une crise terroristes qui
met à l'épreuve sa fermeté et sa
capacité à être souveraine et à avoir
des frontières sûres
c'est un vrai sujet aujourd'hui vous
savez qu'aujourd'hui on a un bon de
porte d'entrée avec la belgique c'est
énorme
j'ai beaucoup apprécié la démarche de
bernard cazeneuve je l'appelais pour lui
dire qu'est ce que je peux faire de plus
il m'a tout de suite dit venez on va en
parler et on va voir ce qu'on peut faire
de plus ensemble
je pense que l'unité c'est pour l'action
c'est pas uniquement pour des postures
dans ceux où voilà où pour se mettre en
valeur et b si la droite est au pouvoir
par exemple à ce que les choses seraient
différentes qu'il ya une phrase assez
terrible de marion maréchal-le pen qui a
dit que les lier aux abeilles d'attentât
en france le 13 novembre si le front
national était au pouvoir avait été au
pouvoir comme si on avait réagi à ce
point et puisque la droite ferait
différemment les choses
d'abord c'est une phrase totalement
grotesque c'est la lutte est d'autant
plus grotesque que je vous dis le front
national a refusé de voter le personal
emery cote
le front national a refusé de voter la
loi renseignement le front national a
refusé l'interdiction des sites qui
appellent à la haine sur internet au nom
de la liberté de pouvoir dire ce qu'on
veut sur internet liberté qu'ils
utilisent abondamment donc la vérité
c'est qu'aujourd'hui ceux qui sont dans
l'action c'est les partis de
gouvernement parce que c'est ceux qui
sont responsables
alors si vous me demandez si je pense qu
on a perdu un peu de temps oui j'ai
trouvé qu'on avait perdu du temps on a
perdu du temps sur la sécurité dans les
transports
moi ça fait des mois et des mois que
j'alerte est et on me disait où vous
êtes en campagne électorale
bon et maintenant il ya une unité et
unanimité que je dois saluer et c'est
précieux cette unité dans les moments
que nous vivons est donc je ne
critiquerai rien aujourd'hui même si je
vous dis dès janvier 2015
j'avais alerté j'avais demandé qu'on
travaille à un patriot act à la
française ça un pétard on a perdu du
temps mais aujourd'hui l'unité que que
nous vivons est trop précieuse pour
composer mutation est ce qu'on a perdu
du temps également dans certains
territoires de la république et
notamment d'île de france selon vous
plairait pécresse est ce qu'il y a des
mullen bec aux portes de paris
je crois que la situation mais je n'ai
pas la nôtre d'abord parce que nous
avons aujourd'hui en tout cas je
l'espère vraiment pris la mesure du
danger qui nous menace et nous avons une
action qui aujourd'hui de 2,2 on a fermé
des mosquées des mosquées qui appelait à
la haine on en a fermé en ile de france
on a fermé la mosquée de lagny-sur-marne
seine-et-marne il ya toujours le berger
nommé communautarisme salafistes vous
l'avez dénoncé durant votre campagne
oui moi ce que je crois c'est que aucune
capitale européenne et la france
l'île de france est une capitale très
cosmopolite aucune capitale européenne
n'est à l'abri de foyers de
radicalisation nous avons en
ile-de-france et foyer de radicalisation
nous le savons et nous devons lutter
contre et nous devons lutter contre
alors j'allais dire savez les dictats
est ce que vous vous adressez à certaine
complaisance politique dans certaines
municipalités par exemple on a pu
peut-être par lâcheté ou vous naïveté
fermer les yeux et il y en a
certainement eu de la lâcheté dabo jour
d'hui aujourd'hui dans certaines villes
bah écoutez moi je vais vous donner un
seul exemple lors c'est un petit exemple
mais pour moi il est il très symbolique
je suis une femme vous comprendrez que
c'est pour moi symbolique le fait qu' on
puisse aujourd'hui à voir des femmes en
voile intégral sur le sol de de l'île de
france dans des banlieues
c'est un signe de provocation c'est le
premier signe il est totalement visible
une espèce de ratification de la loi
géant réclame pas seulement s'appuyer
sur la loi
d'abord je réclame l'application la loi
mais ça c'est minime mais seraient loin
mais surtout qu'on meknes pu me dire que
j'ai pu lire y compris dans la presse
parce que c'était les
et cinq ans d'interdiction ou les dix
ans et 5 ans l'interdiction de la burqa
sur le sol de le sol français que j'ai
pu lire que ce n'était pas un sujet
alors que c'est un signe visible
extérieure d'un début de radicalisation
d'adb de coupure vis-à-vis du foeil
républicain donc en réalité au lieu de
prendre ce voile intégral pour ce qu'il
est c'est à dire une forme de dérive
dans laquelle on estime que la loi de sa
religion est plus forte que la loi de
son pays parce que c'est ça parce que ça
traduit et bien au lieu d'en prendre ça
comme un signal d'alarmé
on a fermé les yeux on a détourné la
tête et on n'a pas voulu voir
oui il ya eu de la lâcheté il ya eu la
lâcheté il y en a encore et il faut pas
aujourd'hui même et l'action là sur ce
terrain là moi je dis d'ailleurs des
choses là mais moi je pense je crois
qu'une partie de jeu de mon élection en
décembre vient du fait que j'ai dit un
certain nombre de choses que je serai
une républicaine intransigeante que je
couperai toutes les subventions
régionales aux associations dans
lesquelles il n'y a pas de respect des
principes de la république de la laïcité
de l'égalité hommes femmes que j'ai dit
que nous irions vérifier dans les
sociétés de transport mais aussi dans
les services publics qui dépendent de la
région qu'il n'y a pas de personnes en
voie de radicalisation au contact des
usagers au contact dans les sociétés de
transport dans les lycées donc tout ce
que j'ai dit dans la campagne je pense à
vous allez mettre en ondes le met en
oeuvre on est en train de travailler sur
une charte de la laïcité pour toutes les
associations subventionnées par la
région parce que nous avons un problème
nous avons un problème de laïcité d'un
certain nombre d'associations sportives
on a un problème de laïcité dans un
certain nombre d'établissements
scolaires où il ya des pressions à la
fois communautariste et j'allais dire
intégrer
la déchéance de nationalité maintenant
elle a du plomb dans l'oeil vous avez vu
après le vote ya quelques instants du
sénat qui a réécrit le texte issu du
compromis laborieux de l'assemblée
nationale entre la droite et la gauche
est ce que vous le regrettez la position
est simple je pense que ce texte n'a pas
sa place dans la constitution la
déchéance de nationalité n'a pas sa
place dans la constitution pourquoi
parce que je suis favorable à des
sanctions exemplaires contre le
terrorisme mais dans la constitution qui
est notre loi fondamentale qu'on puisse
faire la distinction entre deux types de
français ça me choque les sénateurs les
républicains ont proposé de décider
d'une peine de prison perpétuelle la
perpétuité perpétuelle qu'est ce que
vous en pensez
sans possibilité de remise est ce que
c'est une idée qui vous agréent une
pétition pense par exemple à salah
abdeslam de toutes les façons il ya des
peines aujourd'hui de sûreté et de
rétention si une personne qui est
condamné à la perpétuité aujourd'hui
c'est à dire à 20-30 ans de prison ferme
aujourd'hui au moment où il sort s'il
est encore dangereux
oui il ya des rétention de sûreté donc
deux fois ne doit pas sortir
pas question de laisser sortir n'existe
pas aujourd'hui dans le cadre du
terrorisme et d'ailleurs manuel valls a
dit il ya quelques instants qu'il était
prêt à étudier cette proposition venue
de la droite on peut tout étudier mais
d'une manière générale je pense qu'il ne
faut pas laisser sortir un terroriste de
prison il faut le retenir
avec une peine de rétention de sûreté
parce qu'aujourd'hui on voit bien qu'il
y à un certain nombre de personnes qui
ne se sont pas du tout amendé en prison
et donc il faut quand même qu'on
applique la loi telle qu'elle existe
aujourd'hui avec de la rétention de
sûreté
est ce que la peine que le sénat va on
lui proposait elle ne s'appliquera quel
avenir
c'est là qu'elle s'appliquera que pour
le futur moi je pense à ceux qui sont
aujourd'hui en prison